The Texas Chain Saw Massacre is one of the
most important horror films of all time.
Not only did it inspire a half dozen sequels
and reboot films, it was also a completely
new addition to the horror genre that opened
the floodgates of gore.
Leatherface is still one of the most unsettling
villains in movie history, and there's a rich
history behind the first movie in the series
that even the most diehard of Leatherface
fans might be surprised to learn.
Keep watching to learn the untold truth of
The Texas Chain Saw Massacre...
Under the boardwalk
When director Tobe Hooper and writer Kim Henkel
decided to team up again after their previous
collaboration on the low-budget, indie movie
Eggshells, they knew they wanted to do something
in the horror milieu.
But what?
At first, the pair considered a more sinister
version of the already-dark Hansel and Gretel
fable, but then they looked to another type
of fairy tale narrative: Trolls.
"A 5-6-7-8!"
Well, not those trolls...more like these trolls.
If they'd gone with their original thinking,
the movie would've been called Head Cheese
and followed a group of trolls living under
a bridge.
It might've been about as successful as their
experimental Eggshells if they hadn't come
up with a more mainstream concept.
Luckily, they stumbled upon a fatal new idea...
Ed Gein, and then some
Any Texas Chain Saw fan worth his or her salt
knows that Leatherface was in large part inspired
by real-life criminal, Ed Gein, but he wasn't
the only skin-loving psychopath to lend some
creepy realism to the story.
Hooper told Texas Monthly that the idea for
Leatherface was actually derived from a story
his doctor once told about a med school prank
where he cut off a corpse’s face.
"When he was in pre-med school he skinned
a cadaver's face and dried it out and wore
it for a mask to a Halloween party.
So I thought 'Ok that's cool.'"
That's not all: Hooper also looked to a Texan
teen serial slasher named Elmer Wayne Henley.
Hooper explained:
"He kind of puffed out his chest and said,
'I did these crimes, and I'm gonna stand up
and take it like a man.'
Well, that struck me as interesting, that
he had this conventional morality at that
point.
He wanted it known that, now that he was caught,
he would do the right thing.
So, this kind of moral schizophrenia is something
I tried to build into the characters."
Chainsperation
As for the movie's mood, Hooper and Henkel
had to look no further than the news to get
a read on the cultural unrest that existed
at the end of the Vietnam War.
Meanwhile, the idea to implement a chainsaw
as the weapon of choice came from a particularly
terrible holiday shopping trip to a local
Montgomery Ward's.
"I found myself in front of a chain saw display
in the hardware department, and I said 'If
I pick this damn thing up and start it, they'll
part like the red sea.'"
Surprise!
Hooper kept his Leatherface actor, Gunnar
Hansen, quarantined from the rest of the cast
until it was time for him to elicit some real
scares, so when he finally popped onto the
scene, he gave his co-stars quite a fright.
It was just one of the many methods Hooper
would use to evoke honest tension from his
stars.
He admitted in an interview to using a similar
tactic when it came to the wheelchair-bound
character Franklin, saying:
"We wouldn't let Franklin have lunch with
the other actors, and we wouldn't let him
bathe."
Beef ... it's not what's for dinner
One of the central themes of the first Texas
Chain Saw movie was the way that the victims
were butchered in such similar ways to animals.
Director Tobe Hooper, who himself had become
a vegetarian due to the perceived cruelty
of the meat industry, actually used the slaughterhouse
he'd pass by on regular drives as a set for
the film, because it played such a heavy part
in the philosophical undertones of the pic.
He explained in an interview:
"I had an experience in a restaurant one time
where there was a huge trolley with beef being
carved up, and I just transposed different
images onto it.
Like, what if there was a nice little cow
there with a bowtie and a knife carving up
humans?
… It always disturbed me.
It became part of the psychology of the film."
He later admitted that he "thought the heart
of the film was about meat," even though the
characters' cannibalism isn't directly confirmed
in the original.
Others agreed.
In fact, the People for the Ethical Treatment
of Animals, better known as PETA, has given
the film the nod for being among the most
pro-veg flicks of all time, while fellow genre
auteur Guillermo del Toro went meat-free for
a while as a result of the movie.
"From that moment until four years later,
I didn't eat any meat."
Chances seem pretty good del Toro didn't take
the time to see Sausage Party, huh?
"Oh, no me skin!
She's peelin' me skin!"
"Aahhhh!"
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know about
your favorite Texas Chainsaw moment...